[Music]
let's go up to Vancouver and talk to
Amanda what's up
Amanda nothing much how are you good
what are you
doing nothing awesome is this super
weird you're just having a regular day
and then all a sudden
ah yeah pretty much super incredibly
awkward so yeah I've been told I'm am
awkward my whole life so it's all good
good to meet you what's
up um basically I guess sort of my
question is and every holiday my mother
literally and my grandmother will
literally cry in um for literally hours
uh every time I tell them that I won't
be attending the family events uh
including my father's side um I'm half
flatten so that's kind of really um
offensive to them but there did you say
you say you're half you're half
Latin yes gottin col calling on to the
show and it's like very cultural AB at
the same time it's just too much yes and
I can't handle going to some of the
events um most of the time anymore so I
just uh have a hard time every single
holiday or birthday or whatever else
they think is important basically um
why yeah I'll just kind of cut to the
chases okay because I I I totally get
this I'll try you too but I it's very
hard no I got
it do
um why do you subject yourself to hours
of their tears and wailing and nashing
of
teeth um I guess I just think that like
I wish I did I wish I could go I guess
in a way and I I feel like oh I kind of
buy into their guilt over it but at the
same time yeah I guess I wish what
happened didn't happen and I wish I
could go I want to offer an alternative
explanation okay I think you subject
yourself to punishment because you feel
like you should go and this is what you
get for not
going okay and I don't I want you to
know you're off the hook for that what
happened in your family that makes
attending a
nogo it's what's hard is it's not about
all my random relatives it's really
between me and uh one of my siblings or
my only sibling um yeah basically when I
was very young they told me her and her
husband told me that they didn't want me
around because I was kind of like taking
up too much of their Spotlight um on
both sides of the family so what this is
something I still deal with today it's
been 13 years and I still I'm still very
old to still be dealing with that but
well no that hurts but um I mean it's
clearly insane and ludicrous my question
question to you is um what about you is
so small that you let them continue to
run your
life I don't
know like why wouldn't you go and let
your Amanda light shine all over the
family and if they want to opt out
they're welcome
to yeah that's true I mean I wish I
would have done different things when I
was way younger when it happened but um
yeah but we're here now so why not now
exactly yeah um I think just everything
that they hear that I do they go and do
and it just kind of like puts more of a
what pump in it for me like I don't
understand give me an example okay I'll
give you an example so one day like I
decided to go on a hike on a specific
Mountain um it's Vancouver area so and
then like the next months they went and
did the same hike or U one time I got I
had a boyfriend and people really liked
him and then um basically I got cheated
on with my sibling um with that person
um your sister was hooked up with ended
up buying a farm and then they bought a
bigger farm and she bought a bigger F
like that kind of thing so it's just
very you should get a huge fake face
tattoo that would be amazing if you got
like a huge rose on your cheek and be
like what's up and just see if they
actually get do it for real that'd be
amazing that' be
awesome yeah or you should just rent
like a you should rent a Ferrari and be
like look at my new
ride yeah you see how far they'll take
it here's the
thing and I say this with all due
respect who cares what they
do okay no I'm asking you that I'm not
just saying putting that under the
world because when you when you take
them out when you take them off the
table you're doing amazing things you
bought a farm you got a boyfriend your
sister sucks for cheating on him uh
cheating with him on you or what however
youever say that uhhuh but like okay
you're going out doing
life maybe you're doing it so well
you're the ultimate family influencer
and they're like yeah that would be
amazing too or maybe you just have a
sister with a
significant psychiatric Challenge and
it's just she's gonna keep doing what
she does that's her
life okay okay is that fair that makes
sense
yeah yeah taking notes so hopefully that
helps I don't know but I mean here's the
thing if your mom and your mom has a
picture where all of her daughters all
get together perfectly and everybody
does everything perfect and everything
looks perfect and everything's perfect
right yes yes and so anytime there's a
fight in the family it's always oh my
gosh what about me and it and then Mom
cries and then you're supposed to all
make it better your sister's not going
to make it better cuz she's freaking
amazing and so it's your job to make it
better you just said forget all this
right
MH pretty much there's a third
option which is I love my mom I love my
family I like the big messy Latin
holiday parties I've been to a few AG
grpa Texas they're my favorite on the
planet they're amazing and you know they
are they're incredible yeah yeah and I'm
not gonna let a grumpy neurotic sister
over in the corner keep me from
here okay she can go buy what she wants
to buy she can whisper in my ear you're
taking my spoing all right dude I'm
going to continue to laugh and dance and
eat and have fun and love my mom and is
my mom a little
bit yes she is okay does my mom cry a
lot yes she does it's my
mom but if you look around I can hear it
in your story so many things about your
life brought you
Joy one person
squashed a little bit of it and cast a
shadow over everything you love and care
about okay is that fair tell me I'm
wrong I might be completely
wrong uh yeah that's close enough to it
yeah I always try to do something or try
to get over something and yeah this
feels like this is like an overarching
storyline that I'm kind of tired of um
your sister's not going to change is
she no no it's yeah your mom's not going
to change is
she no no not at all
okay so my question for you is longterm
what's going to bring you the most peace
and the most
Joy is it staying at home and saying Mom
it's not my job to make you happy it's
not my job to make you fulfilled and you
have this fantasy of all of your
daughters getting together my sister is
a train wreck and I'm not doing anymore
you've picked her over me fine I'm just
going to stay at home and have peace in
my home here in
Vancouver or is it kids hop in the wagon
we're going to the Grandma's house for
the
holidays and it is going to be unhinged
and we're going to sing we're going to
dance we're going to play we're going to
have fun and tial Loa over here in the
corner is just gonna do her
thing uhhuh right yeah okay but you get
to pick here here's what I'm trying to
get you to see you're in the driver's
seat of your your own
life okay and you don't have a path
forward that doesn't come with some sort
of relational
discomfort okay there's no there's not
an easy path out is that fair right yeah
that makes sense I'm writing that down
okay and so just because it hurts
doesn't mean it's not right and it might
hurt when you're older sister or younger
sister like tries to photocopy your life
or is always one upping
you
um it just a lot so I just don't know
how to even do boundaries really but I
guess those are two good options and
probably reality will probably be
somewhere in the middle I'm not sure
well it's gonna be uncomfortable and
you're going to feel some guilt over the
last 13 years you're gonna have to let
that go okay because that's not going to
solve you right
now okay you're gonna have to say hey
I've made some choices over the last 13
years that have brought me here kept me
safe kept me sane helped me raise my
family here we are great I'm making
different choices Life's too short I'm
going to go be with my family over the
holidays and I've got
one um sister who's just just gonna do
it sister gonna
do and I'll minimize my contact there I
will minimize my kids contact there but
we're family and we're just going to
show
up okay and I would I'm a little
bit I'm the guy that I picked my sister
up professional do makes sense
I know I know I know but listen I picked
my sister up at the airport this year
for the holidays with a huge sign that
said well thank God my sister's finally
gone Aria free and my little daughter
had a sign and said welcome home from
jail and it was
hilarious then my sister called one of
my favorite drummers in all of my life
from the band Poison one my ' 80s metal
band and did a cameo and he called
me sent me a message that said
congratulations on kicking that chyia I
mean that's my brother that's our sister
back and forth that's us
okay it's unhinged it's weird it's silly
it's funny it's just how we interact and
also love her to death and I know she
loves me
too okay but it comes with some ups and
some downs and some sideways that's just
that's just the nature of it okay but
here's what I'm telling you I want you
to feel full fully empowered
to reverse engineer your
life I want my holidays to feel full of
laughter and
warmth and
family what has to be true for those
things to happen sometimes for those
things to be true we can't go visit
extended family it's too violent it's
too volatile we have we have people
there that make it uncomfortable because
they're ugly or they're
rude sometimes it's we're going to go do
those things and I'm going to set some
really firm boundaries about when we go
to bed what kids are going to watch or
not eat or if anyone tells these jokes
we're
out or sometimes it's really clear
boundaries with inside my family hey um
sister so and so ant so and so she says
things that aren't true she Whispers
mean things we're just going to we're
just going to smile and we're going to
ignore we're going to move on because
the end result is warmth and
connectivity in
family so get with your husband and
y'all sit down and ask this question
what do we want the holidays to feel
like my guess is based on this call it's
going to include your mom and maybe even
your
grandma and that means it's also
probably going to include sister so what
do we got to
do or if once and for all I'm not doing
it no more with sister okay it's going
to come at the cost and then I'm going
to stop listening to my mom cry for two
hours I'm going to tell my mom I'm going
to hang up the phone I'm going to send
an email note to everybody my mom calls
robbing I will tell her I love her mom I
can't be in the presence of my older
sister and I know that hurts but I've
got to take care of me and my family I
will call you back and if Mom's going to
sit there and blame and yell and cry
then I'm G to say Mom I'm hanging up now
I'm going let you go and then we'll
reconvene but you get back in the driver
seat of your own
life and don't let one naysayer
one one dark Soul cast a shadow over
your whole life you've got too much to
live life's too fun there's too much
Adventure out
there to let one weirdo take it all from
you thanks for the call Amanda
appreciate you coming in
clutch